now it was due to just be a spring
update without major tax or spending
changes but with the situation in
ukraine on top of an existing cost of
living crisis the chancellor may be
forced into more action with soaring
energy bills fuel costs and a national
insurance rise that takes effect in a
matter of days things are about to get
very difficult for millions of british
families
glad to say the chancellor of the
exchequer rishi sunak joins us now thank
you very much for being with us
this morning um keane of course to talk
to um next about next week very soon but
i just want to start off with
ukraine and it does feel like there's
just more relentless updates every day
today the mayor of mariposa is saying
thousands of residents have been
forcibly taken to russia
i don't know if you know anything about
whether that's true but is there an
update you can give us on the latest
you're hearing from ukraine
well i think as like everyone we're
watching these scenes unfold on our tv
screens uh it's horrifying to watch and
and we sit here in admiration for the
bravery and sacrifice of the ukrainian
people and i think everyone watching
should feel really proud about the
efforts that we're playing as a country
to support ukraine at this moment
obviously people opening up their homes
most recently to take in refugees but we
are also a leading country in providing
humanitarian assistance ukraine 400
million pounds we were one of the first
countries to provide military assistance
to them and again we've played a leading
role in organizing the most severe
economic sanctions something that i and
my team have also been working on talk
about those economic sections but just
on the refugee scheme you mentioned it
was last week that michael gove sat in
that chair and told me that today would
be the day we'd start to see the first
refugees arriving under that scheme do
you know how many refugees have entered
the country under that scheme and are
you planning on opening up your home or
giving a room so in terms of the numbers
what i know is about a hundred thousand
people over a hundred thousand people i
understand have registered their
interests and those checks are going
through now and there's checks on both
sides as michael probably explained
anyone started to come yet though i
don't know if some people started to
come in terms of the visas that have
been approved my understanding is about
uh 25 000 have completed their
applications i think almost 10 000 have
been granted already with the exact
movements of those people i don't know
but those numbers are ramping up all the
time there's more investment in the
processing for all of that and i said
it's uh it's wonderful that we as a
country can can play a role in lots of
different ways are you joining the
scheme yourself no i think everyone will
be helping in in the best way that they
can and that's a full of admiration for
those who can do that you know my wife
and i will be helping in other ways okay
um okay that's fine and so president
zelinski has told russia today that it's
time to talk
how optimistic are you that we could see
a diplomatic solution to the crisis and
liz trust says he thinks she thinks it
may be a smoke screen for russia to
carry out further atrocities after
regrouping yes well i've obviously defer
to the foreign sector and her judgment
on this it encouraging that there are
some signs of talks happening that's
obviously that's obviously good but you
have to have some degree of skepticism
about that given the track record of
these things i think the most important
thing is any any talk of uh settlement
must be on ukraine's terms obviously
and the best thing we can do is just
maintain the significant pressure that
we are bringing to bear on putin but
also providing support to the ukrainians
in in the meantime that's the best thing
that we can do and i said and the
ukrainians will take the lead another
thing that ukraine is calling for is
other countries to effectively
act as security guarantors for any deal
that's signed because obviously it does
feel as if russia is demanding they not
join nato for example so they want
security guarantees from other countries
to protect them in the future is that
something the uk would consider yeah i
think it's it's probably a bit too early
to get into the details of what the
shape of any agreement might look like
and again the foreign secretary will be
taking the lead on these issues together
with obviously the prime minister um but
i think the right thing now is that
continue to put maximum support on putin
both economically through the sanctions
diplomatic and also providing a military
and humanitarian aid to ukraine you know
that's what we need to do
they are they are displaying
unbelievable bravery and sacrifice at
this difficult moment we need to be
standing with them that's what we're
doing and hopefully you know putin will
see sense we promise him very clear we
want to see him fail in this adventure
in ukraine the world has spoken almost
unanimously out against it uh and and of
course we'd like to see a peaceful
settlement but in the meantime we need
to keep up the pressure um as you say we
have seen this unbelievable sacrifice
from ukraine um i just want to play you
a clip of the prime minister i'm sure
you know what i'm going to play for you
um it's a clip of the prime minister at
yesterday's conservative scribbling
party conference let's have a listen to
what you have to say
it's the instinct of the people of this
country
like the people of ukraine to choose
freedom every time
when the british people voted for brexit
in such large numbers i don't believe it
was because they were remotely hostile
to to foreigners
it's because they wanted to be free
to do things differently and for this
country to be able to run itself give
you another example
do you think there are parallels to be
drawn between
the democratic vote to leave the eu
and an illegal
invasion of ukraine where thousands of
civilians have died no i don't think
those two situations are directly
analogous i mean clearly clearly they're
not directly analogous and i don't think
the prime minister was saying that they
were directly analogous either he's not
saying that directly and
i guess but what he is saying the people
of this country like the people of
ukraine choose freedom every time and an
example he gives is brexit
i said those situations are obviously
not analogous right that one is a
democratic referendum in a country where
thankfully we're able to debate uh ideas
in peace and and
join the eu and of course and that and
that should be their right and actually
that's part of that's part of the
situation that putin finds uh was for
him he doesn't like the idea at all
right uh that idea of expression of
freedom but i think i said that they're
not directly analogous situations but i
don't believe the prime minister was
saying that they were either
you wouldn't have used those words
though would you i don't i don't think
the prime minister did either he you
know they are they are not they are not
we just listen to it i don't look people
will draw
the prime minister said so so we're not
taking this out of any out of context at
all and people and look people will make
up their own minds but i i i certainly
don't think those two situations are
directly analogous and i don't think he
does either so you agree with the prime
minister that the people of this country
like the people of ukraine choose
freedom every time such as brexit
i mean i i do think people in this
country prize their freedom of course of
course they do and but there's lots of
different ways that they express that
whether it's through elections through
referendums uh and other democratic
means right now the people in ukraine
are fighting for their freedom it's
pretty crass isn't it though to draw
those two things together i think no one
can doubt that the prime minister has
taken a lead globally in standing up to
putin's aggression that's not the
question i asked well i mean i think
there's nothing about that i mean he's
taken a lead internationally in
assembling a coalition of countries to
inflict maximum economic pain on putin
and he has galvanized opinion and i
think he deserves enormous credit for
that so i don't think anyone could say
that he said you don't you don't think
he said he's not absolutely focused on
making sure we can do everything we can
to support ukrainians at this time a
fact that's been acknowledged by the
ukrainian leadership actually and you
heard that when when when the president
addressed parliament uh but also more
generally i think it's acknowledged that
uk has played a leading role the prime
minister deserves enormous credit for
that but of course these two situations
are not analogous and no one is saying
that they are um whatever happens with
the wall the world has changed do we
need to start to look at increasing
defense spending
well we we had something called an
integrated review a little while ago
which takes a comprehensive looks at the
threats that are facing our our country
and then sets out a plan to address
those before you well actually actually
well it mentioned if you leave that
review it said that russia was probably
the biggest state threat that the uk
faced so in that sense you know credit
to our defense and intelligence team so
have the presidents to recognize that
and that's why we already have increased
defense spending significantly on that
you haven't
this is important so just a you know
year and a bit ago at a time we're in
the midst of chronovirus for most
departments we didn't provide long-term
funding settlements the one department
for whom we made an exception because of
the circumstances was the ministry of
defense and they received a four-year
settlement an extra 24 billion pounds
over the four-year period that's the
largest catch cash uplift in mod funding
since the end of the cold war and will
ensure that we are not just meeting our
nato 2 target but will remain one of the
leading defense spenders in nato and we
did that before but once you take into
account inflation as the russia think
tank has said defense spending is
actually going to be falling in real
terms in 2023 and 2024. you say that
you've met your targets uh on uh the
percentage-wise but the 2019
conservative manifesto pledged to
increase defense budget above inflation
every year
well if you look if you look in the
autumn at the forecast that were
published with the higher inflation in
there what you see is that defense
spending is increasing in real terms
over this parliament it's 24 billion
pounds extra and that was done before
all of this because we knew that we
wanted so no more money for defense
spending i think in general if you look
at what we're doing across public
spending you know we're spending a lot
and the focus has now got to move on to
and i'm sure we're going to get on to
talk about cost of living in people's
taxes you know so let's before we get
into that conversation you know i think
probably the last time i was here we're
talking about the amount that the
government is spending is going up quite
a lot over the course of this parliament
an extra 150 billion pounds more being
spent by government on all sorts of
things defense schools hospitals sounds
like to me no more money i think what
people want is say okay we get that
you're spending a lot of money across
the board we now want to make sure that
all that money our hard-earned money is
going to be spent really well and that's
my phone no no more money for defense
and we we gave lots more money for
defense 24 billion pounds but we did it
okay before everyone else um now of
course we talk about cost of living
there the uk has understandably uh
imposed sanctions on russia as others
have as well
can you level with people on what that's
going to mean for us here in the united
kingdom
so i know this is the number one thing
that people are concerned about and
people are working hard they're
struggling with the price of things
going up i get that i'm spending all my
time focused on that and i want people
to know and they should be reassured
that look i i will stand by them in the
same way that i have done over the last
couple of years to try and make a
difference where i can but as you said
the actions and steps we're taking to
sanction russia are not cost free for us
here at home i can't pretend that it's
going to be easy that government can
solve every challenge or that i can
completely protect people against some
of the the difficult times ahead but
what i can say is where we can make a
difference of course we will that's what
we've done over the past two years and
most recently you saw that with our
announcement to help people with energy
bills nine billion pounds 350 pounds of
support to people they'll get 150 pounds
of that in april so look where we can
make a difference of course we will but
i get that this is difficult how high is
the risk of possession i think you
wouldn't expect me to speculate on that
what i would say to people is they
should feel confident about the strength
of our economy we're actually last year
with the fastest growing economy in the
g7 and if you look at where unemployment
is we are now back to the levels of
unemployment that we saw before the
crisis of very low levels record numbers
of people on payroll record numbers of
job vacancies so the the fundamentals of
our economy are really good because
we've recovered well because of the
actions we've taken but look the outlook
is uncertain as you've said because of
what's happening in ukraine um i want to
get a bit of a sense of your sense of
spending priorities and i understand
there is only so much you can tell us
ahead of uh next week
fuel duty is an area where there's been
lots of speculation about should people
feel that there is action that may be
taken there yeah and i know it's
frustrating for you for people watching
obviously i can't comment on specific
things but what i would say is i
understand that i have a rural
constituency people are incredibly
reliant on their cars and this is one of
the biggest bills that people face or
watching it go up right and we're all
seeing that and when we're filling up
our cards i get that that's why we've
froze in fuel duty already i announced
that in autumn it's the 11th
consecutive year of fuel duty freezes
and that really helps people i know that
and of course fuel duty energy these are
things that people on lower incomes
spend a disproportionate amount of their
income on and it hits them particularly
hard when the bills go up and things are
about to get worse for them as well of
course because in april benefits are
going up just three percent inflation
we're expected to be around eight
percent can you at least say
that you're going to be targeting
for your help that you can give the
people who are going to need it the most
yeah that's that's what we have done
over the past couple of years
i'm asking i'm trying to throw forward
yeah and of course you can always say
judge me by my actions and over the last
couple of years you'll see and all the
research that's published shows this
that those on the lowest incomes have
have actually seen the greatest amount
of support so there will be action you
think targeted towards particularly
those on low income so actually if you
look at what we've already done and
energy you mentioned energy which is a
good one i i i i i i acknowledge you i
want to talk about your record but i'm
just aware of timings well energy this
is something about this is something
that's about to come in right and there
are lots of different ways that you
could help people with energy bills and
you're going to have racial weaves on
later so one thing that the labour party
said is that we should just cut vat on
on energy that is the opposite of
targeted and it would mean someone like
you or me who probably has a larger than
average energy bill would get a larger
discount well actually what we've done
is provide 150 pounds to 80
of british households four out of five
english households that is obviously
going to mean a lot more to someone on
low incomes as you said it's much more
targeted support and it will get there
much quickly so we're doing exactly as
you have said we've um talked about how
difficult things are going to get and
that you can only mitigate so much of
that
but of course this is the time you are
choosing to go ahead with tax risers in
the form of national insurance i think
it's been um it's pretty fair to say
that those aren't going to be going
ahead if you're not going to scrap it
should we expect to see at least some
movement on the thresholds at which
people start paying these taxes i think
you know take a step back why why are we
introducing a new health and nhs and
care levy it's because i care deeply
about the nhs and i know that the
country does as well we were faced with
a situation where millions of people
were going to be waiting years to get
the treatment they wanted as we
recovered from chronovirus
i'll get this
we didn't think that was acceptable for
anybody and we wanted to address it and
the team at the nhs are prepared to work
incredibly hard to work through that
backlog i wanted to make sure that they
had the funding that they need and
deserve in order to to do that and
that's why we're introducing this levy
people can be reassured every penny of
it unlike all other taxes every penny of
this tax goes straight to the thing they
care most about thanks to the actions of
the health secretary they can also be
reassured that it's going to be really
well spent because we're making sure we
root out inefficiency and we're
reforming things and we're actually
announcing more ambitious targets on
that today doubling the nhs efficiency
target in partnership with them which is
great news um but yes ukraine has come
along and it's made things more
difficult but it hasn't changed the
underlying situation that we've got this
monumental backlog that we want to work
through and this is although it's a
difficult decision i think it's a fair
way to do it it's a responsible way to
do it i just want to show you uh the
graph um the following graph now this
shows it's from the ifs and it shows the
uk tax changes under different
chancellors anything above the line is
tax increases everything below the line
is tax reductions and red as labour blue
is conservative so you can see you here
right at the end at rishi sunak
so in two years
you've raised taxes
the same amount as gordon brown did in
10 years how's that um desire for a low
tax economy going i guess what that
chart doesn't show is all the other
chancellors which ones and had pandemics
to deal with
right which one which one of those had
to introduce furlough which one of those
had borrowing higher than at any level
since world war ii that's the bit that's
not on that chart and that bar on the
right is a direct reflection of those
things which are i think anyone would
say pretty exceptional or hopefully
pretty exceptional and that you know no
one last went a pandemic to deal with
over a century ago borrowing had never
been that high since world war ii it's
the biggest recession we experienced as
a country uh ever although in 350 years
so that's not on that chart either
hoping your bar is going to come down i
do think it will come down over time and
we started on that and i point people to
my comments at the budget last autumn
where i said yes have we had to make
some difficult decisions we have i
believe those are the right decisions
there are responsible divisions
decisions for the country's economic
security going forward
but those are done now and my priority
is to reduce people's taxes we started
at the budget and you talked about those
on the lowest incomes earlier the first
tax cut we put in place was on people on
universal credit they face quite a high
tax rate when they're going back into
work we cut that significantly it's a
two billion pound tax cut for millions
of people it will mean a single mother
for example working full-time on the
national living wage will be 1200 pounds
better off so that was the first tax cut
and my priority over time is to keep
cutting people's taxes get that bar down
um and and and that's where we're gonna
head um just finally will boris johnson
lead the conservatives into the next
election yes thank you